sukuna at full power finally Gojo
rattled for the first time their final
battle and more is coming up so make
sure to stay tuned for this crazy
chapter of Jujutsu Kaizen smash that
like button if you enjoy seeing these
Jujutsu Kaizen videos on the channel and
want to keep them coming make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
Jujutsu Kaizen videos and updates and
now without further Ado let's jump into
It spoilers and all so we start with
some hype information urama is
apologizing because one of sukuna's
fingers wasn't found however getting all
the other ones is pretty crazy we really
seem to be at the end game now sukuna is
not worried though saying the last one
is probably in Gojo's possession that's
his hunch and I love this part because
Gojo only managed to Stave off the Bratz
execution he says by proposing it be
delayed until after he consumed all of
sukuna's fingers it's hard for sukuna to
imagine that he would simply be
twiddling his thumbs and waiting for the
ax to fall rather other he imagines that
Gojo has long since stashed away one of
his fingers pretty much delaying the
execution forever love that idea and
it's so Gojo meanwhile though sukuna
says don't stress it he can easily make
up for one finger's worth of Power with
this he'll make up for it with the
shinbutsu mummy now from the sound of it
it does seem like he'll be full power
since the mummy should make up for his
missing finger as he says so we will get
full power sukuna vs Gojo however this
also leaves a possibility and in my
opinion almost certainty that he'll get
another power boost pushing him to new
heights when he gets and consumes the
final finger imagine Gojo just flexing
by giving it to him at the beginning of
their fight that would be hilarious but
since the finger has been mentioned I
feel as with chekhov's gun it will come
into play it's only a matter of time we
then jump to kenjaku who brings up that
a total of 61 players have died by
cursed technique removal because they
never entered a colony he wonders if it
was the thought of dying or killing that
frightened them well in the end lack of
intuition was blamed we seem to get some
social commentary as it said the people
of this country have convinced
themselves that they have no control
over their own reality even when their
lives are teetering on the brink not
everyone has the courage to put their
own life on the line kinjaku says but if
their hand is forced by someone else
they have no choice but to take action
he says it always begins with one step
only then can you make progress towards
your own ideals and he says he holds
nothing but contempt for those who are
unwilling to take that first step after
all when there's no hope left that is
always an option and he says he's
talking to tengen it's interesting
hearing kenjaku's musings and I guess
that's what we look for in good villains
strong characters with interesting
things to say then we jump to Gojo who
says he always thought nanami would be
the type to survive one way or another
and I really wish he did egichi
apologizes thinking Gojo was thinking
why is nanami dead when this dude is
still breathing but Gojo just says how
low is your opinion of me he says to
egachi that he still has a Monumental
task to perform so he should make sure
to give it his all and lastly we're left
with a cliffhanger when we're told Eno
has something to say about nanami and
then we switch scenes but I love to see
nanami still getting loved honestly he
was one of my favorite characters and I
really want to know what this is going
to end up being then we jump to Gojo vs
sukuna's reincarnated body being set up
as a betting game which is hilarious
let's place our own bets in the comments
right now type in either sukuna or gojro
for who you think is going to win I'll
let you know what I'm thinking about all
this at the end of the video but then we
have itadori warming up and training so
this chapter is a sort of breather
setting the stage for the main battles
that are about to take place while Gojo
is 5 fighting sukuna then we jump to
another hype character special grade
Utah okotsu and the always eloquent Toge
inumaki they both make it clear that
itadori is innocent and tsukuna is
solely to blame for the bad stuff that
happened it's fun watching you to
actually know everything Toge is saying
because I definitely wouldn't these guys
will obviously play roles in the final
battle as Utah mentions he'll be putting
Toge to work we now jump to December
24th the most romantic holiday in Japan
as mentioned last chapter the perfect
time for the Gojo vs sukuna fight can
jaku makes his plan and tensions clear
while sukuna is busy fighting Gojo he'll
hunt down the remaining players in the
Cullen game he makes it clear that he
couldn't leave sukun aside before
because Gojo would have killed him
either way though he had no intention of
acting until today because and you gotta
love it strategizing he says if Gojo
loses the only opening they have to beat
tsukuna is right after that battle so
the heavy headers led by Utah can't
afford to leave the battlefield now this
makes perfect sense but is also useful
for the plot because it will give other
characters time to shine as well kenjaku
says as a result he's free to move as he
pleases so obviously sleeping on
everyone else who is not Gojo Yuta Maki
and Kim ji hakari we then jump to these
three plus Panda they're wondering what
to say to Gojo they say do your best and
make sure to come back alive doesn't
feel right they viewed winning as a
given up until now while another says
can't really work up the feeling to be
worried or cheer him on and Toge chimes
in with kelp which is another great
point it's a cool moment to get in a
manga because usually you just get the
corny words and not the thought process
behind them and characters doubting what
to say Yuta says he thinks Gojo will be
happy regardless while Maki looks pissed
saying if he replies with something like
that's a given she feels like she'd beat
him to death before he faces sukan
they're really not only hyping up the
fight but what Gojo will be like and say
leading up to it and luckily it's not a
cliffhanger we will get to see that this
chapter as Gojo shown he looks serious
like he's not as calm and laid back as
usual for once he actually seems worried
itadori of course is like screw the
overthinking he just shows his hand and
says Gojo's curse technique is in the
way of his Sensei and this immediately
gets Gojo to lighten up and laugh saying
give it your best shot pointing to his
back it's great to see itadori and Gojo
smiling as he encouragingly hits his
sensei's back with an open PAW now the
characters are all in a better mood
itadori has completely lifted the
tension and that does seem to be some
shorter protagonist energy right there
like Goku and Luffy then all the
characters give Gojo a pat on the back
as they send him off into battle the
hardest Battle of his life so far
everyone has their own words of
encouragement go get him stupid
blindfold prove to us that you're more
than just a pretty face my personal
favorite salmon I bet you can't guess
who said that and then there's also if
it gets too rough I'll tag you out and
also win gojo-san Gojo smiles and even
appears to be blushing a bit as he says
Roger that nice and simple but notably
he doesn't say it's a given as Maki
mentioned he's not being his usual
overconfident self we then see sukuna's
determined face and he looks terrifying
and not to mention confident the
narrator tells us that the battle
between the strongest is about to begin
the hype is real and like I said place
your bets in the comments if you haven't
already even Gojo seems to know though
that this won't be a walk in the park
and honestly it would be a bit
anticlimactic if Gojo just saves the day
and crushes sukuna without itadori
needing to step up or even help either
way don't underestimate full power
sukuna is All I'm gonna say despite how
awesome Gojo is and if you love strong
characters like Gojo so then you won't
want to miss our all special great
Sorcerers and their powers explained
video link on screen right now and in
the description see you there